[Music]
everything just kind of goes downhill
I think I just found out why we can
never find the dog's ball either why
because it keeps rolling under the couch
over here
our poor babies always losing their
balls because our house is sinking
most of the old float houses around here
are built on logs which when they're new
is great they're super buoyant but
eventually they start to lose buoyancy
oh my God this is so far underwater from
the time that I bought this place about
three years ago I've lost close to a
foot no good and it's gotten a lot worse
just this last winter
get all our line together
start buying these logs up get the first
step done
I think I'd like to get this done before
we end up like that
that's the cautionary Tale
so which logs are we simple we're going
to start with this one here we're going
to work all the way down to the end of
that last one it's floating still okay
my plan is I want to jam some 15 gallon
drums underneath and try and lift the
kitchen end of the house first step I
need to try and strap all the logs
together
so when we do Jam barrels under it the
whole thing doesn't blow apart I'm not
gonna be able to catch this one but I
think that'll be okay
hopefully nothing breaks
pull up a little bit of slack for me
and poor protection there's an energy
here that has faded
it's been hard watching the town get
smaller and
watching you know certain things kind of
Fall Apart
that will work same thing all the way
down okay slowly but surely
I feel a certain responsibility to keep
it alive like to really push
oh it's cold dude oh I know
to be successful and do good show
everybody that you can build a World
here still you don't have to go
somewhere else to do that
I think that's about got it
and unhook you around if you can
oh yeah
all right let's go get some barrels
you ready yes all right
[Music]
I think I have to cut those into 45.
nothing's stopping me but fear itself
[Applause]
I think 45 to me
these two sticks of aluminum are gonna
turn into a small ladder we put it on
and take it off the side of a boat
two four six got it it'll be good enough
for who it's for
I've got a unique opportunity here
to find out what the hell's down on the
bottom of the ocean around here
a new friend of mine
wants to go down and we want to go out
and see if we can Harvest some sea
cucumbers
been looking for a diver for years and
one finally moved here I'm going to be
his dive tender that's not bad
I First Met Troy probably two years ago
he uh jumped off the airplane I think he
had a some kind of a weapon on his
shoulder I had my suspicions but first
conversation like I said within 30
seconds man wait up
you know it's like never judge a book by
its cover and since then we've become
good friends Troy
there he is when I got hot off the press
[Applause]
it was a struggle but I but I figured it
out
figured it out
I like it that's gonna work great I
think it's time to see if we can get us
some creatures yeah some dinners
I'm originally from just outside of
Seattle in Kirkland Washington
for many years as a senior finance and
consultant
and I've always been very very
competitive had to be number one
everywhere I went and that was just very
very soul-sucking and draining to me I
think Brutus not a bad way to
start the day
my dad had been a banker for almost his
whole life
when my dad was in hospice I asked him
do you have any regrets and he he didn't
even have to think
um and he said with tears in his eye
that I I worked too much and that really
hit me and stuck with me and started uh
pushing me uh rolling down this hill to
where I am now
the big push now is getting the cabin up
it's because I am currently living in a
in a big canvas tent
I know it's going to be a lot of work
but it's my Never Never Land
sure we just don't want to do a night
dive tonight uh I think we'll practice
during the daylight a little bit it's
probably just about as dark down there
as it is at night you're ready to go in
the water
[Music]
how many cinder blocks did you end up
with out of your load well out of the
175 uh 160 of them made it intact
but I'm just gonna have to Pare down
what I was planning on doing for the
double wall on the back of the chimney
there for uh the heat break we got to
get going on it garbage is building up
Roger that baby
so what I'm building basically is a
rocket stove to incinerate trash
and has three chambers to it the first
one will be the hopper the burn chamber
the second will be the actual place
where most of the combustion happens and
I'll have an eight foot chimney up the
back that'll be a four foot by four foot
so it should have excellent draft
this is going to be a massive
incinerator that'll actually burn stuff
down to nothing
I'm gonna be able to share this
incinerator with the entire neighborhood
when you make everybody's life a little
easier or just you know lend a hand
that's what really makes the community a
community
it's good
nice
so those are going to be the two main
pieces of the framework that the whole
thing's gonna ride on
that's going to work out nicely
I want this incinerator to last for the
rest of my days if this one lasts a
couple decades
I'll be smiling
around here in Port protection we are
the Next Generation us younger people
and so I definitely feel the pressure to
be successful
[Music]
there
all right
sweet
we bought a bigger boat is this boat
really kind of solidifies us as
fishermen it's a whole new horizon for
us to just explore so to speak
we have a loan that we have to
have to play gambling
bring that the fish will show up and we
can just make this boat work and it's
going to be fishy for us
basically we're going to go over
and uh grid our boat
finally get to
know what I paid for pretty much I
bought this boat
pretty much sight unseen
you hope that the person was honest and
Soldier is something worthy but you
never really know until you see it for
yourself
when we go out on the grid you just set
your boat right down on this platform
and you can see the hole and see what's
going on in the bottom of the boat and
you have to set it just right if you set
it too far back and you crush your
Rudder up into your hole that's no good
not knowing this boat and how it what it
takes to Grid it's uh nerve-wracking
this is kind of might do me in as far as
business-wise goes really hard to
recover from that
all right now if you want to swing the
skiff around to your Sterns right here
okay we'll start getting this rigged up
and ready
[Music]
the float house is slowly but surely
sinking into the ocean
not a good thing
we are currently attempting to defy
nature
and resurrect
not unlike Lazarus
all right that should
hopefully work
the theoretical idea here is we pull the
barrels really hard with the skiff
underneath the float house and they
Lodge themselves between the logs that's
good in theory
ethereum practice two different things
I'm gonna go back there and start
Levering okay let me know when you're
ready come on
stay
being a newcomer in Port protection I
have a huge learning curve
I am very confident in the fact that I
can drive in a straight line but it's a
whole new ball game pulling a barrel
underneath my house
my biggest worry is when those barrels
go under the house that it's going to go
through our kitchen floor and
potentially breaking our house go
whenever you're ready
a little more oomph to start
there you go
go go go go
go go go go go
okay you gotta show me how to do this
because this is come on back off really
frustrating me I'll learn you
Morgan really wants to do well in
everything she does now are you gonna be
perfect the first time always no so as
long as I'm there letting her know that
it's you know it's okay to fail a little
bit
we'll figure it all out
[Music]
let's go ahead and go back uh this Watts
there
I'm gonna give it a little rip here and
see what happens
[Music]
yeah I lost a handle all right
he's gone
see what I got I can make a handle out
of
I know I got something around here
that'll work
I think you're not just a cleat I could
bolt a cleat on there real quick if I
can find one
how many cleats in here everybody's
gotta have a junk pile you never really
know what's gonna break for me it's a
status symbol you know I see somebody's
yard I'm like man that is a nice pile of
junk you got
there we go that'll work right there
perfect
we'll bolt it on there and it should be
stronger than ever okay bolts
you think this one's gonna hold
[Laughter]
[Music]
it
I love it when I can cut a cut a square
line with chainsaw
Jiggy
right there looks pretty good
[Music]
when you live out here on the Ragged
Edge it's always a task and a chore to
try to get rid of all the waste that we
have you don't have a garbage truck
pulling up to the end of the dock here
and taking away all the crap that you
generate hold us on the inside corner
there
so the way we've dealt with garbage is
burn it bury it sink it or carted off to
town
this rebar is going to be spikes to pin
on the timber frame together
[Music]
out here rebar is pretty cheap 12 Inch
Nails not quite so much so MacGyver
moment
cut a nice little head in it grab your
Maul or your sledgehammer and oh look
I've got a 12 inch nail
oh look I've got a dozen of them
see how they work out for me
[Music]
should be pinned
lordy we all take extreme joy and pride
in the fact that we live in the natural
world
and when you see a clump of trash that's
been burned on the beach and floating
around in the tide line or up on the
beach
it's heartbreaking
leave the world a better place than you
found it
and so pretty much the ethos of most of
the people live out here I think it's
actually coming together pretty well
they say I'll uh fill in the gravel so
that I can come up to level pain here
for gravel here's to hoping we can still
keep all our
bits and pieces and Murphy doesn't rear
his ugly head
I don't know how something's just full
of air can be so heavy
you ready I think so I'm ready now
you're diving all right rock and roll
but want to make sure there's some keel
it sits about right here because if it
says too far forward we're gonna get our
Rudder feeler boat perfectly right in
the middle here maybe a little bit more
yeah hopefully
this is where we have
here you can't give me your hand
nice a little bit it moved this is like
trying to fit a square peg into a round
hole
too tight oh there you go can I get a
grip on it we'll figure this out yet
that thing is like
okay
fighting a bull constrictor
I think the lad needs to lose about 15
pounds
I don't think it should be that hard
there you go finally got to do one nah
the optimum outcome from this whole
diving exercise for me would be a mess
of sea cucumbers because I haven't had
them in for 25 years
actually I should have been craving them
ever since but without having a diver
living here
your Sol oh we're having some fun
[Music]
and he's away he's Off to the Races
this is a first for me and seeing how
I'm not a diver and I don't have a bunch
of gear if something does happen to him
when he's down there he's he's on his
own
[Music]
it's 1am
parking on the grid here at night
because uh the tides are going to be
kind of small tomorrow afternoon
and I'm not sure if I'll be able to get
on and off
yeah sometimes the only time that
presents itself is right in the middle
of the night it's not optimal but
it's just what we got
it's the first time that we've gridded
this boat so a little nervous about it
a lot going on when he grid this thing
you got to make sure the pilings are
just right everything's lined up
don't want to smash the rudder with the
weight of their own boat
I don't want to be someone that someone
hears about one day
a little nervous a little nervous I
don't know where that beaches over here
what's going on
there it is real close
but now a little bit here
yeah
pull the bow in
it
oh ouch
I gotta get out there find something
Italian too
really have much
a little anxious about all of this
definitely gonna settle uh as the tide
goes out so we just don't know how it's
going to settle bad things can happen
where a boat will shift and then it can
roll completely over so
we'll see probably not gonna be a lot of
sleep
let's see what we got huh
be careful coming off this ladder Brown
it's really sketchy okay
it's a new boat and until you get the
boat on the grid and see what's going on
you really don't know what you got
you're hoping that the money that you've
already paid you don't have to put any
more into it
how's it look down there
how's it look wondering curious
it's it's the perfect dude it's better
than I could have hope for man awesome
yeah I mean come check it out hell yeah
wow it does look great
sweet
yeah it looks like he just freshly
painted it man oh yeah see that's pretty
much what needs to be done the zinc's
got to be replaced they're all eight
away and
that one there is kind of gone and that
bugger there but
boy I think we got what we paid for man
we definitely gotta good deal here
really
well let's get cracking man sweet
I'm hoping I can get this done here
before the tide comes in around me
[Music]
probably have almost a thousand Dives
under my belt but that doesn't mean
anything
really is a different world
you know we're not meant to be 40 feet
underwater
you can never get overconfident about
diving at all
25 years ago my buddy spent I'm going to
say 15 minutes down there
came up with a nice bag of them hanging
off his
belt and we had a hell of a good feed
fond memories
[Music]
I get in the water here visibility is
not awful
sand crushed shells everywhere
looks like the Otters had a field day
with uh
just about everything down there
he's been down there oh half hour now
anyways I'm expecting that uh
seeing how he hasn't pulled on this
thing sooner probably pretty slim
picking
[Music]
oh I hear I hear the ladder rattling
there he is okay there he is
what did you see definitely you could
tell the sea otters have been here a lot
of eating mussels and uh yeah shells
everywhere they've they've been feasting
here no doubt
not a single sign of seafood
you hear that yeah I hear that
oh yeah
yeah
steady stream
it's coming out of this one fitting
right here
that explains the air going pretty quick
huh
it's not easy to get the stuff out to
the dive shop or get it back
it is not quick it's not cheap
it's a bunch of BS yeah
just these little hose down
these are our zincs right here that I
gotta replace
I'm hoping that everything works out for
him
the zincs are basically grounded into
the steel here
it just is where the electrical stuff
that's like where the ground of your
batteries hooked to is all into this
stuff that's all connected and it just
basically is a sacrificial metal so like
stuff like the prop and the shaft and
The Rudder doesn't get ate away
then this is the last sink just in time
as the water is coming up
[Music]
doesn't fit Hey Brianna yeah you wanna
come on down here okay
so we got kind of something going on
here we're gonna kind of try to make
this bugger fit where this one came off
of and it's kind of presenting a
challenge
it could just come off and then my whole
shaft and prop won't have any
electrolysis protection it'll really fit
in it'll start getting eaten Away by the
electrolysis yeah and that's I mean this
is easily a thousand dollar or more
propeller right here and I can't afford
that right now all my money's got to go
into boat payments
with this tide coming in you think we
have enough time or I can run back and
grab the grinder and
if you're fast I think we have a little
bit of time right um well if I can find
it and find my cutting wheel and stuff
all right
[Music]
definitely the ties start to come back
in
we'll get off the beach on this time
we're going to be stuck here for quite a
while it's not going to be good
[Music]
yeah just be good and ginger on the
corners go one at a time instead of
trying to two-hand them if it'd be
easier because like I say we got no
margin for air when it comes to material
loss
I've done some construction
but most of it is self-taught and uh the
nature of the Beast is often necessity
it's just how it is we're getting
somewhere now darling
um one two three four five
I don't like that much
and sitting high in the middle
can't have that going on
why is that happening uh there might be
a little too much gravel humped up in
the middle there on one side that's not
gonna work on the chimney right
yeah all right
this simply will not do
the the whole the whole base plate is is
a little bit uh convex and I need it to
be concave to the instead of spreading
out as I build the chimney up it pushes
in on itself I'm gonna have to figure
out what to do about you
[Music]
all right baby so
to make sure the chimney doesn't start
trying to split apart on us
I'm gonna Jack this up here I got some
nice pressure treated material there
that's actually a wedge and as soon as
you lift this up I'm going to try to
pound that into the uh the very edge of
the uh the framework on both sides and
that should be enough to get the concave
form off the base
definitely already got some weight on
her
sweet I'll have to pound crap
let her down
there it is oh yeah look at that it's
all this brick
ah don't you love it when a plan
eventually comes together
[Music]
the Tide's coming in kind of quick right
now and I'm rushing against the clock
[Music]
grab one of these for extra just in case
always be prepared all right let's get
out of here
since it was our first time griding the
boat we didn't really know what zincs
we'd buy and so I kind of just guessed
and got what I figured you know would
work
just gonna buzz off a little bit of this
end here
another one of the props didn't really
fit right and so I'm definitely
concerned about that one the prop is an
important part of the boat you know and
if that thing starts to get you know
eaten away with electrolysis it'd be an
expensive fix and so I'm hoping that
everything works out
all right Brian just hang on to this
booger like that okay and I'm gonna
cut off on this thing down here
all right
all right it's rough enough to go on my
boat damn it was too nice I wouldn't
know what to do
oh
[Music]
with the tie coming in around my ankles
I just got to roll with what I got right
now
oh
cool yeah sweet yeah well I definitely
got it on and it definitely is tight so
far I'm a happy camper at the nick of
time heck yeah all anything left to do
is get off this thing go catch a fish
let's go see what it's got
[Music]
come on dogs load up
We All Aboard yep
Moment of Truth
oh we're moving
oh yeah
[Music]
all right
The Sun Shines on a dog's ass every now
and again
[Music]
oh look at that oh yeah look at you
cannot hear it but you can sure as hell
see it I think you got a faulty hose
here well we can put a Band-Aid on it
this is a self-fusing tape it fuses
itself together and I patch the garden
hose with it once
let's try it on the life support system
it's gonna be a thing where I'm Gonna
Keep A much much better eye on the
pressure gauge
I mean it doesn't matter if you've dope
hundreds or thousands of time your next
Dives your most important dive you have
to take it very very seriously
I'm gonna give this a good soaping down
now
that looks looks good well
Horseshoes and Hand Grenades
okay let's try that again okay oh lordy
lordy lordy look who's 40.
okay I'm gonna go for it give her hell
baby
[Music]
keep this whole thing from sinking
we should be good right here just stop
right here
[Music]
gearing up
and then let's get wet
[Music]
although Sammy science Works 99.9 of the
time
this is my life we're dealing with here
with this air so we don't want to be
going down super deep with uh with hose
that's not quite at 100 percent
[Music]
he's still breathing
I'm not a diver
I catch things with a hook and line
maybe a gun nut
the idea of going in there and trying to
get something with my bare hands
I have a philosophy stay out of the
water
[Applause]
been in the water a long time got to be
just about out of here now
I know
Papa's getting farther from the boat
there's some little pocket caves down
here along this Cliff it's a ways down
and hopefully he can maybe make it to
those
there are little pockets of life I'm
hoping that the sea otter can't deal
with because it's in the wrong spot
coming back
[Music]
I thought he might be coming up with the
basket but I got a yes
what'd you get uh we got a little one
well
I see him that's what you call pretty
thin soup
pretty soon soup That's Not Gonna Fill
the freezer
no it's not
foreign
Beautiful Creatures actually they get
much larger they get you know that big
around and that long and that's the kind
you're really looking for this one here
is just a baby
that would be not even a snack oh we
didn't get skunks but we didn't wow
that's a skunk in my book if it had a
dozen of them you know we'd be talking
that would have been let's have some
sea cucumber strips supper
well a Trip's pretty much over we're out
of here let's see our total take was
one sea cucumber I think we just got our
asses handed to us burn me please
I'll get over me is that pretty much
pretty too hot no it's all right
it feels like I peed down my leg though
but I'm looking forward to uh you know
the next 10 years becoming somewhat of
an expert about the dive industry now
that I have somebody that lives in the
community and it's always good you know
to have a younger fella around
especially when he's got a sense of
humor you know your water rolls off your
head like a duck
I think you're waterproof you gotta get
your toys in a row
having a relationship with the
old-timers out here is huge and I lucked
out uh meeting the right people out here
that you know kind of take me under the
wing like Sam has and uh I think Port
protection has a lot more Bounty for us
to get I think that this is the tip of
the iceberg well I'd say Troy this is
probably just the beginning of this
operation well we literally got our feet
wet sure
go go
went straight to the front whoa
see how that worked
they do what it wanted to do
well it's there and it's not gonna move
oh
let's do a couple more yeah all right
oh lordy
[Music]
it went down awesome
looks like we might have come up another
a little bit too yeah
more protections changed a lot since I
was young and away we go
a lot of people die a lot of people move
away
[Music]
fishing's gotten worse progressively so
there's not really a strong drop I am
hoping this is the last Barrel we have
to stick in here
last one's the charm
where we're going I have no idea but I'm
gonna be here
you know for the Long Haul building up
our Empire
getting us where we want to be
[Music]
success
I think with the barrels under there
we've increased the longevity of the
house by five to ten years maybe and
maybe when I'd move out and get over the
new property we get to pass that on to
somebody else that needs a quick starter
house let's uh clean up and see if
anything rolls around the house now
looking pretty level
four and a half thousands
it's definitely exciting to be able to
get some hooks in the water
and uh
I'm really excited to eat some King
Salmon the tides are just right this is
a sport trolling it's not open for
commercial right now
but getting a boat out and testing it is
what's important
[Music]
sure
there's a lot right riding this season
with our new investment with this new
boat
we have a bill now that we have to pay
so we're gonna have to fish hard we're
just hoping that we're gonna get
something out of it and be able to like
stay afloat
[Music]
hey dude damn it dude
took my splasher
[Music]
yo he is laughing at me
nice oh man
I can tell Oliver really wants to catch
a fish like really bad and he gets
really a fish fever kinda
just like any fisherman they get very
like
sensitive
these are Patrol and I got my lines in
the water this would be a perfect time
to uh
definitely check my out oh what do we
got going on here
on it
foreign
oh no
dude
it's about like the equivalent of
catching a boot
I caught a life jacket strap
starting to wonder about the luck on
this boat now
[Music]
man I had high hopes for this summer
more fish than this
is one of them
[Music]
what's going on here
it's probably the
[Music]
weirdest day I've ever had trolling in
my life
maybe move but go try trolling someplace
else it doesn't seem like there's a much
in the bay usually after a couple passes
one will bite her it won't
no
a man
oh it is a fish we got a fish neutral
we got a fish
right there
[Music]
come on burgers
in a good position here he's my right
it's a nice one
okay we're gonna be pulling no don't
don't man don't go to him let him come
to you okay
oh no
oh straight up pull straight up all
right there we go hello
yes there we go we got one whoa
our boat's fishy the boat's catching man
woo
I feel like I caught a fish man I feel
like a stud yeah hell yeah hell yeah
pull it on the Dick there it is
but it seems to be fishy glad to see it
catch something
now it's just a matter of getting into
the commercial season and seeing how
everything works out for the long run
let's go prepare a dinner a dinner
should I want
first of many first of many
[Music]
oh yeah that's gonna be fun maybe don't
I'm gonna get a hand
oh yes
grab it
these cinder blocks are about 36 pounds
apiece
man this is going to be a pain in the
herbals
all right mother Glory when you gotta go
over your head and lift them way out
when you're awkwardly standing it can be
a bit of a challenge
there was this guy that built a tower
back in Italy that's called the Leaning
Tower and uh I really don't want to go
there
[Music]
if I got my darling right underneath me
man and I'd this way definitely don't
want to drop anything on her head so
it's a matter of taking my time not only
do I have a very slim window as far as
materials go but uh safety out here is
always Paramount
foreign
[Music]
all last breaker
oh God I love that one
[Music]
ready for the maiden voyage baby yes
there's always uncertainty
you never know exactly how things are
gonna pan up
especially when you're flying by the
seat of your pants light this up right
off
oh yeah there we go the draft's already
starting to pull it
yeah this thing's going to incinerate
when a plan actually does come together
and works out the way you hope it does
there is no better feeling in the damn
world what do you think doll was it
worth pulling all that gravel in that
heavy ass break up yes it was I think so
too this infrastructure it'll be big
enough it'll last and I know we're gonna
have plenty of people coming up lighting
a fire
man this is a Exquisite addition to the
back 40. go see if we can't collect a
little bit more okay sounds good
I did this last night after we got done
[Music]
no more rolling no more rolling no more
rolling We're not gonna find weird out
of the couch anymore
moving here in the beginning was
something that I really had to get used
to
but it's been such a wild ride and I am
lucky to say that I have the best
partner in the world help me out with
this
villages in Alaska are losing their
populations Court protection is no
different dinner is served
so it's real important for you know
people like me to pass along as much as
I can to these younger Fellers I want
more
wrestling for the rest
having the my roots here in Alaska is
really important to me and I definitely
think that this new boat is going to
help us keep living this lifestyle and
maybe even have kids it'll be big enough
it'll be safe
you've only got yourself and your
neighbors to count on
it's important to pull up what slack you
can this is the MV Orca up in Baker just
letting everybody know I got my
incinerator built today so if anybody
needs to get rid of some refuse give me
a holler back on 74. I wear quite a few
hats around here I chair the community
council volunteer on EMS and Fire
but uh wouldn't want it any other way
because I know that my neighbors are
pulling slack too look at that fire pit
[Music]
thank you